my name is lauren price and i'm a
networking specialist customer engineer
at google cloud today i'm going to talk
to you about some networking concepts
for gke that are helpful to know for
implementation security and connectivity
stay tuned
google kubernetes engine or gke provides
a managed environment for deploying
managing and scaling your containerized
applications using google infrastructure
in gke a cluster consists of at least
one control plane and multiple worker
machines called nodes
the control plane runs the control plane
processes including the kubernetes api
server scheduler and core resource
controllers
a cluster typically has one or more
nodes which are the worker machines that
run your containerized applications and
other workloads
the individual machines are compute
engine vm instances that gke creates on
your behalf when you create a cluster
the control plane runs in a google
managed vpc and the nodes run in the
user vpc
there are so many things that we could
talk about related to gke and networking
but we're going to focus our
conversation today on just a few
concepts all related to standard gke
clusters
gke clusters can be distinguished
according to the way they route traffic
from one pod to another pod a cluster
that uses google cloud routes is called
a route space cluster a cluster that
uses alias ips is called a vpc native
cluster
bpc native is the recommended type and
is the default for new clusters in newer
versions of gke
because route space clusters are no
longer recommended we'll focus more on
vpc native clusters
vpc native clusters have several
benefits
pod ip addresses are natively routable
pod ip address ranges do not depend on
custom static routes instead
automatically generated subnet routes
handle routing for vpc native clusters
you can create firewall rules that apply
to just pod ip address ranges
pod ip address ranges and all alias ips
in general are accessible from
on-premises networks connected with
cloud vpn or cloud interconnect when you
create a vpc native cluster you specify
a subnet in a vpc network the cluster
uses three unique subnet ip address
ranges
a primary subnet ip address range for
all node ip addresses a secondary ip
address range for all pod ip addresses
and another secondary ip address range
for all service addresses
it's important to plan ahead with
respect to sizing your gke clusters to
make sure enough ip space has been
allocated and the desired scale can be
achieved
by default gke allocates a slash 24
alias ip range to each node for the pods
running on it on each node those 256
alias ip addresses are used to support
up to 110 pods
this can be reduced if ip space is
limited or that number of pods isn't
needed
keep in mind that when creating clusters
in a shared vpc environment gke cannot
manage secondary ip address ranges
a network admin in the shared vpc host
project must create the subnet and
secondary ip address ranges before you
can create the cluster this is unique to
shared vpc only
bpc native clusters have the option to
be created as public or private
public clusters deploy the control plane
and nodes with public ip addresses so
they can be accessible over the internet
for the control plane authentication and
authorization is still in place to
restrict public calls and the worker
nodes can be protected by firewall rules
but what if you need a cluster with an
increased security posture
private clusters are better in this
situation
private clusters use nodes that do not
have external ip addresses this means
that clients on the internet cannot
connect to the ip addresses of the nodes
unlike a public cluster a private
cluster has both a private and public
endpoint for the control plane
you must specify a unique slash 28 ip
address range for the control plane's
private endpoint and you can choose to
disable the control plane's public
endpoint
in private clusters the control plane's
vpc network is connected to your
cluster's vpc network with vpc network
peering
a common vpc network peering connection
is used if the clusters are in the same
location and use the same vpc network
remember that because the gke control
plane uses a peering connection you must
keep in mind the network location of
where you are trying to access the
control plane
if your control plane access is
separated by more than one peering
connection you'll need a proxy to access
the private endpoint or you'll need to
use the public endpoint
one important topic to discuss when it
comes to routing is the use of ip
masquerade agent
ip masquerading is a form of source
network address translation used to
perform many to one ip address
translations
by using the ip masquerade agent gke can
change the source ip address of packets
sent from pods to the source ip address
of the node the pod is hosted on
masquerading a packet source is useful
when a recipient is configured to
receive packets only from the cluster's
node ip addresses
now that we've talked about how to
access the control plane let's talk
about how to access services hosted on
the private gke clusters
there are many ways that services can be
exposed but today we'll focus on three
services of type load balancer the
ingress object and the gateway api
all of these options make use of native
google cloud load balancers and provide
container native load balancing features
using network endpoint groups
meaning traffic is load balanced
directly to the pod endpoints
eliminating the number of hops the
traffic must take
let's start with service of type load
balancer
the idea of a service is to group a set
of pod endpoints into a single resource
in a kubernetes cluster each pod has an
internal ip address
but the pods in a deployment come and go
and their ip addresses change so it
doesn't make sense to use pod ip
addresses directly
with a service you get a stable ip
address that lasts for the life of the
service even as the iap addresses of the
member pods change
the service also provides load balancing
clients call a single stable ip address
and their requests are balanced across
the pods that are members of the service
when you create a service of type load
balancer google cloud configures a
network load balancer in your project
the load balancer has a stable ip
address that is accessible from outside
of your network a network load balancer
is passed through meaning it forwards
packets with no change to the source and
destination ip addresses
external clients call the service by
using the load balancer's ip address and
the tcp port specified
the request is forwarded to one of the
member pods on the tcp port specified by
target port an ingress object defines
rules for routing https traffic to
applications running in a cluster
an ingress object is associated with one
or more service objects each of which is
associated with a set of pods
gke ingresses can either use the
external https load balancer or the
internal https load balancer depending
on the source of your traffic
multiple backend services can be exposed
through the same ingress object and
traffic can be routed using the url map
on the load balancer
additionally we have the gateway api to
provide access to services as of the
making of this video the gateway api is
still in preview
the gateway api is an open source
standard for service networking the
gateway api evolves the ingress resource
and improves upon it by providing api
resources to correspond more closely to
organizational roles of cluster managers
aligning with open source standards and
providing more advanced traffic
management features natively rather than
having to use custom annotations
the gateway api contains the following
resource types
the gateway class defines a cluster
scoped resource that's a template for
creating load balancers and cluster
a gateway defines where and how the load
balancers listen for traffic
cluster operators create gateways in
their clusters based on a gateway class
gke creates load balancers that
implement the configuration defined in
the gateway resource
an http route defines protocol specific
rules for routing requests from a
gateway to kubernetes services
gke supports http routes for https based
traffic routing
application developers create http
routes to expose their http applications
using gateways
now let's jump to a few security topics
private gke control planes have both
public and private endpoints and users
have the option to use authorized
networks on both of the endpoints to
allow list access to specific ip ranges
other security features to consider are
using iam to assign fine grain control
to users and service accounts
interacting with the gke cluster
role-based access control can be used
inside the cluster
a role can be scoped to a specific
kubernetes object and defines which
actions the role grants in relation to
that object
workload identity allows a kubernetes
service account in your gke cluster to
act as an iam service account
pods that use the configured kubernetes
service account automatically
authenticate as the iam service account
when accessing google cloud apis
using workload identity allows you to
assign distinct fine-grained identities
and authorization for each application
in your cluster
finally firewall rules can be used to
protect traffic to clusters while
network policies can be used to protect
traffic within the clusters
so let's summarize the three most
important takeaways from today
there are vpc native and route space
cluster types as well as public and
private clusters
make use of service type load balancer
the ingress object and gateway api for
container optimized load balancing
make sure your cluster and control plane
are properly protected with authorized
networks firewall rules and network
policies
thanks for watching if we missed any
topics you'd like to hear more about let
us know in the comments below and look
out for another video on the concepts of
networking for google cloud's managed
services
[Music]
you